what is pan psychism like what are the
different
ways you can try to
to think about to define pan psychism
maybe in contrast to uh
naturalistic dualism and materialism and
other kind of views of consciousness
yeah so that you've basically laid out
the different options so i guess
probably still the dominant view is
materialism that
roughly that we can explain
consciousness in in the terms of
physical science wholly explain it just
in terms of
the electrochemical signaling in the
brain
dualism the polar opposite view
um that consciousness is
non-physical outside of the physical
workings of the body and the brain
although closely connected
um and you know when i studied
philosophy we were taught basically they
were the two options you had to choose
right either you thought it you were
duelist and you
thought it was separate from the
physical or you thought it was just
electrochemical signaling and yeah i
became very disillusioned because i
think there are big problems with both
of these options
so i think the attraction of pan
psychism is it's kind of a middle way
it agrees with the materialist that
there's just the physical world
ultimately there's just particles and
fields
but
the pan pancychist
thinks there's there's more to the
physical than what physical science
reveals and that
the ultimate nature of the physical
world is constituted of consciousness so
consciousness is not outside of the
physical as the duelist thinks it's
embedded in
um underlies
the kind of
description of the world we get from
physics
what what here are the problems of
materialism and dualism
starting with materialism
i
it's a huge debate
but i think that the core of it is that
physical science works with a purely
quantitative description of the physical
world
whereas consciousness
essentially involves qualities if you
think about the smell of coffee or the
taste of mint or
the deep red you experience as you watch
a sunset
i think these qualities
can't be captured in the purely
quantitative language of physical
science and so as long as your
description of the brain is framed in
the purely quantitative descript
quantitative language of neuroscience
you'll just leave out these qualities
and that's really leave out
consciousness itself
and then dualism
so i've actually changed my mind a
little bit on this since i wrote the
book
so i mean i argued in the book that we
have
pretty good experimental grounds for
doubting dualism
and roughly the idea was
if dualism were true if there was say an
immaterial
mind
impacting on the brain every second of
waking life that this would really show
up in on neuroscience you know there'd
be all sorts of
things happening in the brain that had
no
physical explanation it would be like a
a poltergeist was playing with the brain
um but actually
and so the you know the fact that we
don't find that
is a strong and ever-growing inductive
argument against dualism but actually
that you know the more i talk to
neuroscientists and read neuroscience
and we you know we have a durham my
university an interdisciplinary
consciousness group
i i don't think we know enough about the
brain about the workings of the brain to
make that argument
um i think we know we know a lot about
the basic chemistry
how neurons fire
neurotransmitters action potentials
things like that we know a fair bit
about
large scale functions of the brain what
different bits of the brain do
but what we're almost clueless on is how
those large scale functions are realized
at the cellular level how it works
um you know people get quite excited
about brain scans but it's very low
resolution you know every pixel on a
brain scan corresponds to
5.5 million neurons and we're only um
we're only 70 of the way through
constructing a connectome for the for
the maggot brain
which has is it 10 000 or 100 000
neurons but you know the brain has 86
billion neurons so i think we'd have to
know a lot more about
how the brain works
how these functions are realized
um
before we could assess whether they can
be the dynamics of the brain can be
completely explicated in terms of
underlying chemistry or physics so um
you know we'd have to do more
engineering before we could uh figure
that out and there are people with other
proposals um
someone i got to know martin picard at
columbia university who has the uh
psychobiology mitochondrial lab there
and is experimentally exploring the
hypothesis that mitochondria in the
brain should be on the sort of sort of
social networks
perhaps as an alternative to reducing it
to underlying chemistry and physics
so so i i'm less
it is ultimately an empirical question
whether dualism is true i'm less
convinced that we know the answer to
that question at this stage
i think still as scientists and
philosophers we want to try and find the
simplest
most parsimonious theory of reality
um
and dualism is still a pretty inelegant
unparsimonious theory you know reality
is divided up into
the purely physical properties and these
consciousness properties and they're
radically different kinds of things
whereas the psychist offers a much more
simple unified picture of reality so i
think it's still the view to be
preferred
you know to put it very simply why
believe in two kinds of thing
when you can just get away with one and
materialism is also very simple but
you're saying it doesn't explain
something that seems pretty important
yeah so i think materialism can't you
know we try science is about trying to
find the simplest theory that accounts
for the data i don't think materialism
can account for the data maybe dualism
can account for the data
but pan psychism is simpler it can
account for the data and it's simpler
what is pan psychism
so in its broadest definition it's the
view that
consciousness is a fundamental
um and ubiquitous feature of the
physical world
like a law of physics what should we be
imagining what do you what do you think
the different flavors of how that
actually takes shape in the context of
what we know about physics and science
and the universe so in the simplest form
of it the fundamental building blocks of
reality perhaps electrons and quarks
have
incredibly simple forms of experience
and the very complex experience of the
human or animal brain is somehow
rooted in or derived from these very
simple
forms of experience at the level of
basic physics but i mean maybe the
crucial bit about
the kind of pan psychism i defend
what it does is it
it takes the
standard approach to the problem of
consciousness
and turns it on its head right so the
standard approach is to think
um we start with matter
and we think how do we get consciousness
out of matter so i don't think that
problem can be solved for reasons i've
kind of hinted out we could maybe go
into more detail
but the pancitis does it the other way
around
they start with consciousness and try to
get matter out of consciousness so the
idea is basically at the fundamental
level of reality there are just
um
networks of very simple conscious
entities um
but these conscious entities because
they're behave they have very simple
kinds of experience they behave in
predictable ways
through their interactions they realize
certain mathematical structures
and then the idea is those mathematical
structures just are
the structures identified by physics
so
when we think about these simple
conscious entities in terms of the
mathematical structures they realize we
call them particles we call them fields
we call
the their properties mass spin and
charge
but really there's just
these very simple conscious entities and
their experiences so in this way
we get physics
out of consciousness
you